and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less
my name is Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist
today we're gonna talk about the most
precious kind of freedom awareness we're
talking about living intentionally we're
gonna talk about mindfulness we're gonna
talk about meditation we're gonna talk
about purpose well well sort of we'll
talk about purpose maybe we'll argue
with our guest today about purpose and
we're gonna we're gonna answer your
questions with today's guests the host
of the making sense podcast is here sam
harris is in the studio thanks for being
thanks so much man yeah well this is our
first public conversation since our
documentary which was awhile ago
and thank you for being in that by the
way yeah honestly I didn't even know
quite what I was in hey I know you had
told me what your theme was but really I
didn't discover it until I actually
watch the documentary so the fact that I
said something relevant to your
documentary but might have been an
accident but if people have really
enjoyed that film and it's you know I
get a lot of good feedback for it so it
was perfect man it was like it was a
great accent a great yeah opinion a
great point if you'd add into the
documentary I know yeah definitely
people found a ton of value in your in
your segments for sure
well the reason we want to bring you in
today is you have a meditation app and
it's called waking up and Ryan and I
have tried a bunch of different
meditation apps we have a mutual friend
Dan Harris who isn't a great meditation
app called 10% happier
I've tried calm I've tried headspace
I've even tried meditating without an
app and I've got to tell you we'll talk
a bit about this my wife and I we just
finished day 50 yesterday and so I had
to do two yesterday it took us about 70
days to do the first 50 days I'm so glad
to hear that man because Moriah and I we
just finished day 15 yesterday and it's
it's taking 17 or 18 days to get to day
15 so I'm glad like yeah I'm glad I'm
not the only one that isn't on it every
single day well I've learned quite a few
lessons we're gonna talk about those
today now saying the way this show
usually it works is we don't do
interviews we use our audience questions
as sort of jump off points for
discussion so let's dive into some of
these
our first question is from Katherine in
Seattle I'm a new mom and I work and I
am wondering how does the concept of
minimalism fit within the complexities
of our life and the realities of
spending your day doing things like
chasing a baby
cleaning out covers following them as
they're pulling things out you know is
there this place tenable being accepting
of the chaos of life and that minimalism
might be sort of an elitist unrealistic
ideal that doesn't allow for people to
fully just embrace and accept that life
is messy and unpredictable and full of
chaos and it's not about eliminating the
chaos but it's about how do we walk
through the chaos I guess was great so
you know what's fascinating about this
question she talked about minimalism but
I would just replace the word minimalism
with mindfulness Ryan and I talked about
minimalism it often starts you with the
stuff but our material possessions are
sort of this this physical manifestation
of what's going on inside of us quite
often really like we're just the
minimalists because the domain was
available for 8 bucks like when we
started writing about this stuff you
know almost right exactly we tried to
get to simpletons calm but it just
didn't have as good of a ring to it so
so Sam I think what's what's fascinating
I don't know if you ever get this this
question or even you know it's like a
under it's like it's a sneaky criticism
in a way or like is mindfulness only for
elitists in a way and when I talk about
minimalism Ryan talks about minimalism
what we're talking about is the
intentional use of our resources when we
think about resources we think about our
stuff and our money but the most
precious resource we have is our
attention and so maybe maybe you can you
could talk about how do we navigate the
chaos yeah well I'm glad you said that
that final part of it are the most
precious resource being attention
because we think of it as time and it is
that too but obviously you can misuse
your time if your attention is scattered
or you're paying attention to the wrong
things
so yeah you each you have this moment in
this moment in this moment and you never
get them back again and it is it the
value of your life is cashed out in
satisfying or unsatisfying uses of
attention in each of those moments so
yeah first we shouldn't minimize how
difficult it is to raise kids and
certainly in the beginning I me but it
is you know it's and when you have do
either of you have kids go okay so you
you you know you you know what's going
on here it's just a in each chapter of
raising a child it seems like that
chapter is never going to end but
obviously it's always changing and you
know infancy doesn't last all that long
although its interminable or when it one
is there and yet so you have to be
realistic about how much time you're
gonna have to do anything you other you
want to do other than keep this this kid
alive but ultimately mindfulness is not
a matter of having a formal practice
although having a formal practice is
incredibly useful I mean it is a
training and that's why people like me
build apps or you know this is why I
went on retreat when I was young a lot
and it's like learning to do anything
it's like if you want to learn to play
the piano you have to at some point sit
down and study how to play the piano and
practice but the actual practice is just
it's realized in moments brief moments
of being clearly aware of what is
already happening you know so once you
find what mindfulness is as a as a just
an act of cognition once you once you
discover what it's like to be aware of
anything with true acceptance without
judgment you know you're just being
bombarded by pleasant and unpleasant
stimuli and in every moment of your life
and most of what you're doing is just
thinking about all that you're thinking
about the past you're thinking about the
future you're trying to manipulate your
experience in a way that that makes it
more gratifying or reduces your anxiety
and mindfulness is the mode of just
stepping back and being aware of sensory
experience and the flow of thought
without trying to push or pull anything
right and and so at once you can find
that and it doesn't take that long to to
find out how to do that again it's a
totally esoteric skill if you've never
trained it at all and if most people are
don't have a moment like this in their
lives really until they learn how to do
this but once you've learned it it is
not at all a matter of setting aside an
hour a day to do it formally right if
you could punctuate your day with a
hundred or you know a thousand you know
as many as you could you can find clear
moments of just interrupting your
reactivity in your judgment and your
rumination that's what the practice is
and that ultimately is compatible with
with a fairly chaotic and certainly busy
life we talk about chaos I think part of
the chaos and it's obviously been amped
up and in today's social media world the
internet world the we have this
bombardment of you know half a million
discrete bits bits of input on our life
every day it feels like and
advertisements and everything else it
feels like we're always trying to get
somewhere I was I was checking my email
this morning Gmail said it got to this
point where I said you have no mail
please enjoy your day as if I have to
wait until I have no mail in order to go
out and enjoy the day and you talked
about this and some of the lessons on on
your app where it feels like we're
always trying to get somewhere and then
we're gonna bask in the sort of joy of
being there but but most of the life is
in most of our lives of it is the
journey itself yeah I think there's a
lesson there why talk about this
illusion I was living under which I
hadn't recognized and a friend pointed
it out to me about it was I was at lunch
with a friend and complaining about all
of the stuff I had to do I was just I
had a to-do list that we just had
many small and not so small fires I had
to put out and I was just feeling very
stressed out about it and the you know
that there were two levels at which I
could address this problem one is just
become mindful of the stress become
mindful of the thoughts and cut through
it moment a moment but and that's
incredibly useful to do I think that's a
necessary skill if you actually want to
be sane ultimately but the there's a
meta cognitive framing skill which in
some cases is even more important
because they because if you're just
mindful of a situation like that it
keeps recurring
you keep it's just you you're stressed
out about all the stuff you have to do
and you're always going to be in a
situation where there's a lot of stuff
you have to do and you just keep just
trying to tune up your mindfulness in
the face of that anxiety but to reframe
it can fundamentally change your your
relationship to this thing and so my
what my friends had in that case is did
you actually think there was ever going
to be a time where you didn't have a
to-do list you know I mean is it like is
that is that is is your effort to knock
out the things you need to do predicated
on this notion that you're going to get
to a place of just you know you know
to-do list zero that is going to remain
for any period of time and do you even
want me what would you actually want a
life where there was nothing on your on
your to-do list and what it what are you
actually even aiming for here and I
realized it was a completely false goal
that I was I hadn't even consciously
formed it was just the subtext of
everything I was doing and feelings like
I have to have to solve these problems
but every every day of the rest of your
life on some level is gonna be about
solving problems and so you have to once
you acknowledge that you can drop back
and actually just relax into that's
that's what it is and so that's a that's
the kind of thing that you get a lot
from stoic philosophy I would say you
know like if you read the meditations of
Marcus Aurelius that's that's a great
reframing on many fronts I mean he's you
know he would
you should start your day acknowledging
that over the course of this day you're
going to meet you know many disagreeable
people who are going to criticize you
and you know present impediments to your
happiness and and just having that
framing can give you much more patience
with with you know anything that all the
things that are inevitably going to come
yeah I totally agree I mean the you know
minimalism or mindfulness can help with
that framing absolutely I mean you know
for me like with minimalism or with
mindfulness I never looked at it as a
substitute for chaos I never looked at
it as a substitute for problems like
problems and chaos I mean like you said
I mean those those are guaranteed things
in life minimalism helped me to kind of
hit these things head-on rather than
what I used to do which was I would mask
it with drugs and alcohol I would I'd
stay really busy so I could kind of you
know ignore these problems add to the
chaos to soothe the chaos and exactly
yeah it's like somehow in the moment
adding to the chaos was better than
actually sitting down and trying to face
those problems head-on but like when I
look at how I look at my problems now
being mindful like I start to ask myself
meaningful questions like you know how
did I get here what decisions that I
make to get to this point how did this
problem arise what can I do to learn
from this how can I be more intentional
to not create problems like this in the
future and you know I think ultimately
minimalism is a tool that personally I
used to get use to get clear on what
truly matters in life and when we can
really get clear on what truly matters I
mean we can kind of cut out all of that
superfluous mind clutter or maybe it is
some physical clutter but we we know
exactly or maybe we don't know exactly
but we have a much better idea of what
we can just start kind of chopping out
and in feelings that we necessarily
don't have to perpetuate or really you
know dive into yeah I think I think when
we when it comes to what matter is like
when you when you start to figure out
what that is then all of a sudden the
angry tweets they
become less meaningful to us right where
as if we're clinging to the acceptance
of of other people etc to sort of get
our self-worth if that's what truly
matters with us and it seems incredibly
chaotic but I'll say the other thing
that seems that really illustrates the
the chaotic nature of everyday life is
when you're meditating even when you're
essentially doing nothing and I've
learned this from from Sam and his app
in particular it seems you know it's
just chaotic even when I'm doing nothing
right my mind is where the chaos really
is yeah entirely it's really it's never
a matter of the world even if the world
is presenting what you know on its face
objectively our circumstances where any
rational person would would feel anxious
or to even terrified the the the cash
value of anything that's happening in
the world is always your mind and it's
it's it's possible to have a mind that
is deeply a quantum ascend you know 99%
of people would be would really have a
really struggle with and a be the and
this is the important point to recognize
is that the time to develop a strong
mindfulness practice is not when you
really need it right I mean this is a
insofar as you acknowledge that this is
this kind of skill is trainable which
certainly is though most people don't
understand that it's the time you want
to train it it's when life is quote
normal it's not when something horrific
has happened which and something
horrific is gonna happen to all of us I
mean it's just you know the people close
to you are going to die you're going to
face medical emergencies personally and
and with people you love and you know
the stress gets turned up to 11 for
everybody at some point and the quit and
so you either invest something in
preparing for that or you don't
and you know you get the the people have
a natural range in how sensitive they
are to stress and how resilient they are
and a lot of that's genetic no doubt but
wherever you're at training your
attention in this way can be incredibly
useful in it so there's a very
straightforward analogy it's just
physical training right you know we all
recognize that you know very few of us
are going to become Olympic athletes but
the kind of training that would make
someone a an elite athlete is it's the
same kind of training that we all can do
to just be more resilient physically and
healthier physically and you know so
push-ups work for everybody unless they
have some peculiar injury to their
shoulder say with it and that they have
to work around but it's it's a that
their standard exercises physically that
we that we know are good for you and
again this was this was esoteric
knowledge 100 years ago 100 years ago
you were just this goofy guy in that
Leopard cingulate a single singlet at
the circus you know a whole hosting the
dumbbell over his head and you were part
of the freakshow right and and so now
you just have a gym membership yeah
exactly
well Kathy Norma send you a copy of our
book essential there is a mindfulness
chapter in there there's also a chapter
on priorities and I think quite often
for mindful of what our real priorities
are I think quite often we give lip
service to what we say our priorities
are so like my Health's a priority or my
relationships are priority but within we
are spending most of our day checking
email or browsing Facebook and I think
the truth is our real priorities are
however we decide to spend our 24 hours
today yeah those end up being our
priorities so there's an entire chapter
about priorities in there and then Sam
if it's okay with you I'd love to send
Katherine a one-year subscription to the
waking up app and we'll find a way to
make that happen on the backend I think
the the waking up app that is the first
app that has helped me to understand
that there is this you know there's this
cognitive piece of me that is kind of
translating all of those bits of
information and and I think you do a
really
awesome job with helping to identify the
bits of information and then that that
cognitive piece of the mind that is that
is kind of getting all this bits of
input and the one thing I want to talk
Catherine too is elitists still have
problems they might not have money
problems but they still have problems
you know what time it is it is time
before our lightning round where we
answer questions from social media so
Sam here's what we usually do we try to
answer these these questions with the
short shareable less than 140 character
pithy response we call these minimal
Maxim's
but that's not actually what we do we
just Mandar on a bit until we until we
figure out a something that is
adequately pithy that Shawn can tweeze
out and put in the show notes yeah and
then I think we put all the the pithy
quotes in one place now minimal Maxim's
com
I dug up to sort of problematic
questions about meaning and purpose
because I knew we would be able to have
a fun conversation about these so what's
our first question Ryan the first
question is from Angela you guys often
talk about living a meaningful life what
does it mean to live a meaningful life
and how can mindfulness help Sam Sam
thoughts well so this question about
meaning comes up a lot because you know
as you know I've been very critical of
religion and the one of the things that
people think they get from religion is a
very clear story about what life means
and in the absence of that kind of story
they think well they've been robbed of
something that's crucial to living a
happy life and I think it's a false
problem I think so the question of what
does life mean is the kind of question
you ask when again your attention is not
making satisfying contact with the
present moment when you're when you're
actually experiencing your life directly
in a way that's satisfying that is
precisely the sort of moment where you
don't think what does it all mean like
what's the whole was the point what I
often think about is I don't know that
life has a particular meaning but it's
still possible to live a meaningful life
and I know that sounds like semantics
but but the way that we get to a sort of
meaning
for life and my pity answer is a
meaningful life exists at the confluence
of one's values and actions I think we
have a set of values you know or what
you might call morals from your book the
moral landscape and and you obviously
want your actions to align with what
those morals are you might have an ideal
set of morals but for acting the
opposite of that then you're in some
sort of a moral Valley so to speak and
and and so I think it's possible to live
a meaningful life even if we don't know
or if there isn't a a meaning of life
you know there's no question it's just
that the again look at this this concern
for what it is because the people
articulate this concern most clearly are
you know often advertise themselves as
nihilists right they're people who think
there is no point to life and it
actually wouldn't be a bad thing if we
all died in our sleep tonight I mean
it's like it's just this is not
suffering is bad but if we could just
cancel the whole human experiment that
would be fine on some level your podcast
to who I feel is named David Bennett are
the anti-natal hosts and I made a list
cetera never to have been born right so
so this is why people like once you get
these gears turning people find a lot to
say and a lot to worry about in this
area and what I always say and in this
context is that this is essentially a
mood disorder masquerading as
philosophical insight so like people are
seeing that the world through the lens
of their state their their emotional
state of consciousness and through that
lens you can say what's the point of
anything I mean the laughter of a child
is just like what's the what's the
[ __ ] point
you know and yeah and so why are you
enjoying that Ella it's pointless and
use it like so if you're not taking joy
in your experience and your you feel
disconnected from other people and you
don't sufficiently care about their
conscious state so you're not like so
compassion and
kind of the warmth of the present moment
is not felt it's it's just so everything
is antiseptic then in that context and
in the and so honestly many of these
people are depressed I mean people who
find this this way of thinking very
compelling are often depressed and yeah
then it's then you can kind of drop at
the bottom of your engagement with the
world and you think well there is no
point to anything and so I understand
that but but and and I've actually had
to talk to people who are suicidal in
this place and they think they've
reached there their compulsion to kill
themselves based not on any kind of
problem of mood but based on a
philosophical insight they actually
think they have reasoned their way to
the brink right and it's very hard to
talk to people and I hear because they
have an answer for they have an answer
that is intuitively satisfying to them
for everything you're going to say like
you know the you know what is the point
if we all die right and that's and the
problem with that particular meme as
that has become the foundation on which
so much of a dogmatic defense of Iron
Age religiosity has been hooked I mean
it's just it's like that is one of the
first things you hear from people who I
mean you hear so many crazy things from
people who are gonna gonna defend
fundamentalist religion but you hear
things like well without religion life
has no point without religion there's no
reason not to rape and kill your
neighbors like as though everyone is
just just you mightily tempted on a
daily basis to rape and kill their
neighbors and it's the only the only
thing stopping them is a belief that
they'll they'll spend eternity in hell
if they do it so this is a again it's a
false problem but it's not it's not at
all obvious to most people there's a
false problem but I would just say it
can be obvious to you in those moments
when you are making truly satisfying
contact with your experience whether
athletically or relationally or
intellectually or sexually or Maywood at
whatever those moments where you are no
longer looking over your own shoulder
wondering when experience it's gonna pay
off right in the moment where we might
call peak states or flow States Cal
Newport when he talks about deep work
and these moments never am I asking
myself like what's the whole point of
this I'm just I'm thankful in a way that
isn't I'm not even using language to
articulate the it's just like there's a
feeling of thanks or gratitude of wow
I'm actually living in the moment there
is this moment and I think it's why I
often it feels so good like this is I'm
actually experiencing the moment it's
not about necessarily the outcome it's
not about you know what I'm gonna have
for dinner tonight or whatever it's
what's going on right now yeah miniature
when you think about what it's like to
see a film that you really love right
you're totally engrossed in this film
the fact that the film is going to end
is not a reason not to see the film
right like it does it doesn't diminish
the value of doing this he nobody says
in the middle of a truly absorbing film
well the fact that this is only two
hours long it just makes this I can't I
can't enjoy this you know this is I'm
done right like and yet people think
that somehow life conforms to that kind
of geometry where the fact that it's
only 70 years or 90 years diminishes its
beauty or value or interest or that's if
if anything the opposite is the case the
fact that this is the only circumstance
of being that you can be absolutely sure
you have makes it incredibly precious
yeah in a moment-by-moment yeah my pet
the answer is the best life is a value
driven life so very similar to what to
what Josh was saying but I mean for me
you know I'm on the I'm agnostic I guess
I mean I was raised like really hardcore
Jehovah's Witness I've realized I've
realized like you know with that and I'm
not going to get into it but you know I
realized why
don't want to be part of that
organization so you know I'm still kind
of up in the air with stuff but what I
do know is that when my short-term
actions are aligning with those values
when they're aligning with these beliefs
that I have right now which I might not
have these beliefs in ten years they
might completely change but I know that
when my actions are in alignment with
those things that is where I start to
find meaning and purpose kind of pokes
its head out - along the way but but the
best recipe for discontent is going
against what you believe in and going
against your values - to answer Angela's
the last bit of a question how can
mindfulness help well I think if you
don't know Angela what your values are
what your beliefs are I mean get clear
on those so you know at least what steps
you need to take to start heading in the
right direction and again I think
mindfulness minimalism Simplot whatever
you want to call it simplicity that
helps kind of clear out all of those
superfluous things so we can take our
most precious resources and focus them
on what is truly important our next
question is from melodie what's my
life's purpose can mindful can
mindfulness help me pursue that purpose
and I think so this is an extension of
what Sam was just saying a second ago
but IIIi all I have is a pithy answer
for you if life has a purpose that
involves suffering and problem-solving
and that's usually not the answer people
want to hear right but but your life is
going to involve some sort of pain or
suffering there's no doubt about that
but to echo what Sam was saying a second
ago from the lesson from the waking up
at is you're not gonna get to a point
where you have no problems and by the
way if you get there and you stay there
for too long you're gonna be bored out
of your mind with absolute certainty it
might be what we're looking for
and we think but it's not actually we're
looking for I think yeah real
fulfillment comes from from actually
solving the problems themselves well I
think we get caught up in like and join
it being the purpose of life or being
happy being the purpose of life but like
you said it's like if if you had nothing
but enjoyment and happiness in your life
like that's eventually going to be a
dull
right what's called mania my father was
was manic-depressive and schizophrenic
and and he had manic states the
elaborate relationships with people who
didn't exist in the real world and often
had you know just fits of mania and and
that's that's at the terminus that's
sort of the the extreme almost parodic
example of of this but yeah life isn't
about just ephemeral pleasure and I
think too often we we confuse it as such
yeah yeah just to be clear what
mindfulness is is the condition of
noticing what your experience is like
without being lost in thought about it
right so that people are spending their
their time and 99.9% of their time lost
in a story they're telling themselves
about their their lives and everything
in the present moment no matter how
pleasant or unpleasant is coming through
this this filter of endlessly
conceptualizing and discursive Lee
narrating and reacting to and judging
experience and what you discover when
you learn to be mindful is that
consciousness is just that that in you
which is aware of experience has certain
characteristics which which are which
can which convey the relief and
well-being that you are otherwise
disposed to seek through all your
efforts right so it's like it's like the
on some level we're all of our efforts
to solve our problems are a matter of
trying to have a good enough reason just
to be able to relax into the present
moment really relaxed so that you just
you can just put down the burden of your
life
and give up the war and just come to
rest right and and so as you say Joe
it's not about always you find in a joy
that doesn't go away or finding a peak
experience it doesn't go away because
whatever is whatever comes is going to
go right and the other would what you
have is you have this condition in which
things are continually appearing and
changing this is you know consciousness
for lack of a better word and it's and
it is never a matter of getting some of
the contents of consciousness to persist
for all time because that that's
impossible I mean it is it's
neurophysiological impossible it's just
it's as the the physics of things the
nature of something that arises is to
pass away and yet this condition in
which everything is arising and passing
away sight sound sensations thoughts
moods emotions that is it really is open
and unstructured and and the more you
drop back into it just and just witness
the flow of experience the more you
begin to feel the freedom that comes
with just recognizing that that which is
aware of joy is the same thing that's as
that which is aware of sadness or
depression or fear or anxiety and it is
actually not deeply colored or in or in
the end colored at all by what's
appearing and so that's that so the key
to finding deep equanimity even with a
quintessentially negative experience
like sadness or you know physical pain
is to recognize that consciousness
itself never actually takes the form of
of what it knows and it's just as you
know there are many analogies here but
it's you know one it's like it's like a
mirror you know whatever you put in
front of a mirror it's it is reflected
by it it's completely apparent within it
and yet the mirror never takes the shape
of the ugly thing that has been brought
before it as never improved by the
beautiful thing that's been brought
before it and you can actually and then
again takes some training to do this but
when you really establish an experience
of mindfulness where it's you know
you're you you're mindful for long
enough so that you can really test the
character and quality of consciousness
in in many moments strung together you
can see that yeah it's there is a
phenomenon that you know the Tibetan
Buddhists call one taste to where it's
just it doesn't matter what your
experience is in those moments and so
it's in those moments and again those
can be you know hard one for some of us
but in those moments it really is a
matter of not being able to find any of
your problems right now they you'll pick
them up again in the next moment when
you're thinking about your life but it
is it's an incredible relief to know and
to experience this kind of interruption
of reactivity where you just see like
you know whatever else is going on in
your life you can actually find real
rest again if only for a moment but you
could do that a hundred times a day and
that's and that's well that's what the
the training ultimately is yeah I
totally agree my pithy answers is this
the purpose of life is to live as
meaningfully as possible and we talked
about what a meaningful life is during
the last question but just to reiterate
from melody
don't confuse meaning with happiness and
excitement that is that is just part of
the overall process which is if you're
suffering you're lost in thought that's
net and that is I mean as an algorithm -
or heuristic to have running in your
brain that's it's incredibly instructive
because yeah I guarantee you if you are
psychologically miserable in any way you
are just you have been thinking
continuously without noticing it and
until you know how to be mindful
there will be no alternative but once
you know how to be mindful you will be
able to interrupt that that process yeah
absolutely
looks like podcast Shawn has put
together some surprise questions for us
this week we'll see how many of these we
can get - is social media making us less
mindful how do I stay mindful of my
personal values despite others values
being thrust upon me in the workplace is
ambition helpful or harmful can
psychedelic drugs help with mindfulness
how do I eliminate distracting trivial
thoughts so I can focus on the task at
hand and also I want to chat with Sam
about why advertisements suck we don't
do any advertisements on on this podcast
shout out to our patreon supporters
thank you so much
also meditation for children my
daughter's gonna raise her in sick so
we're gonna talk about this as well
there's some stuff in your app and three
things I have learned from Sam Harris
about meditating and if you want to hear
all that you can listen to this week's
maximal episode available exclusively on
patreon that's right you're currently
listening to our weekly minimal episode
but each week Ryan and I and while Sam
this week we record an entirely
different long-form maximal episode
exclusively on the minimalists private
podcast which gives us the private space
we need to talk about a whole bunch of
stuff that we can't always talk about in
public Plus patreon is the best way for
us to fund this podcast and keep it a
hundred percent advertisement free when
you subscribe to the minimalist private
podcast on patreon you'll also receive a
personal link so that our maximal
episodes play in your favorite podcast
app you also get access to our entire
back catalogue of more than a hundred
private podcast episodes find all the
details and all the good stuff including
additional private podcast episode every
week over at the minimalists comm slash
support ryan what else you got for us
this week you know being informed is
more important than ever these days Josh
so I just want to encourage people to
read more and get informed and now here
are some voicemail comments and tips
from our listeners Josh and Ryan its
Connor from Toronto I'm 17 and I'm a
patient grade 11 right now so exams are
coming up and my mental clutter is
coming to all-time high right now so I
use something to help me focus on
studying and writing that I recently
started using and it's an app called
Pomodoro timer so that's P om o de Oro
it's a really simple timer app and it's
based on a kitchen timer that uses a
Productivity practice called the
Pomodoro Technique it's a time
management method that's used to break
down work into intervals traditionally
25 minutes of concentrated work
separated by short five-minute breaks so
after a number of cycles reward yourself
with a long break that's usually 15
minutes and on the app you can adjust
the duration of the work sessions and
breaks you can set daily targets and you
can even catalogue your progress over
time so I found it that overtime I've
been working more productively and
getting more out of my study sessions
and I hope you define value not to
Thanks hi my name is Natalie
I'm from Cochrane Ontario so I want to
start by saying that I really enjoyed
your recent stop buying podcast I would
like to share how I limit my shopping on
Amazon I only pay with gift cards when
shopping online so as I have added the
items to my cart I then have to buy a
gift card at the store and apply it to
my account before finalizing my
purchases this makes buying online less
convenient and it allows me to think
before I buy if it is not worth my time
going to a store and buying a gift card
then I probably don't need the items in
my cart alright y'all thanks again to
sam harris for joining us today make
sure you check out his meditation app
it's called waking up and check out his
wonderful podcast called making sense
you can find all that at sam harris dot
org and real quick 4 right here right
now here's one thing that is going on in
the life of the minimalists exciting
news y'all we're currently working on
our fourth book yeah it's called the
messy minimalist by Ryan Nicodemus calm
no it's it's called love people use
things so we've been we've been using
this tagline for a while now and it is
really the embodiment of our message
when we talk about living simply about
living with less living a meaningful
life with less it often has to do with
how do we decide to love people more and
just use things because the opposite has
has crept into our lives we're loving
all of our things and we started using
people and we always say the opposite
never works right and so it's a
relationship book right it's let's talk
a little bit about it it's sure the
eight essential relationships in our
lives
yeah well it's funny because when you
think about relationships you just think
about the people right but there are so
many other things in our lives that we
start to form relationships with whether
it's our technology or whether it is
like actual people right our stuff will
now use our relationship with our self
or a relationship with the truth right
right because and so what we want to do
is sort of illuminate each of these
these eight areas and we're doing
right now with some of our patreon
supporters 47 different families are
participating in a packing party right
now
and it's not just so you can pack up all
your stuff it's a bit of like a case
study we're doing these 47 different
case studies and it's not just about
packing up your stuff in an unpacking it
that's part of it but we're getting over
2,000 bits of data from these folks what
is your relationship with the truth what
did you learn about your relationship
with yourself throughout this process
your relationship with your family and
other people in your life your
relationship with your creativity how
did that change or what did what did it
illuminate for you and so we're going
through this book and it's different
from our previous books because the
other books included some sort of
stoical or personal experiments we've
done and some other insights we have and
this book will certainly have that we're
also taking an individual case studies
other people's experience yes and
forwarding it in here I mean we know
what a packing party looks like for
single guy Ryan Nicodemus but what does
it look like for a family of five right
yeah and and so taking other people's a
case case studies and experiences
folding those in with our own empirical
wisdom and insight but then also one of
the experts have to say on these
different areas right because you and I
might be experts on minimalism but what
is what are the experts about money
saying about our relationship with our
finances yeah and so let's look we're
gonna talk to a lot of folks about that
now the book won't be out until 2020 or
maybe even 2021 because there's a giant
election we're working on it right now
but in the meantime until that book
comes out you can support our work if
you'd like by buying one of our other
books we have three books I tend to
recommend them in this order everything
that remains is the memoir that Ryan and
I wrote well mainly because it's the
best thing we've ever written yeah III
think so but it's it's it's sort of a
why behind the what in the how the next
book that i recommend is minimalism
talks about the five values and that is
the what book for me so you start with
the why you go to the what and then
essential is the book that is sort of
the howl to book so the why - the what -
the how to in that order everything that
remains minimalism essential if you're
gonna start somewhere I'd recommend
everything that remains you can find all
of those books on our website or if you
can't afford to buy one of those books I
strongly recommend going to your local
public library
yeah they usually have it or if they
don't have in stock they're really happy
to order them for you there are
thousands of libraries throughout the
United States who have our books or will
order our books for you and you can
check them out there for free also
today would be my mother's 74th birthday
Oh Ryan so I just wanna say thanks to
her real quick she died 10 years ago
this year and it was the the insights I
learned from that whole experience that
led us down this path toward minimalism
and so in a way she never got to see any
of this come to fruition unfortunately
and I it's unfortunate I would love to
be able to share this with her but she
was able to well the death and her own
struggles illuminated a path for me to
move forward us to move forward and live
a more intentional life and so wrote
about her experience in everything that
remains as well if you have a question
comment or minimalism tip for our
podcast leave a voicemail for 0 6 2 1 9
7 8 3 9 or send a voice memo to podcasts
at the minimalists comm you can comment
on this episode at youtube.com slash the
minimalist if you want our show notes in
your inbox sign up for our email list
over at the minimalists comm and you'll
also receive our simple Sunday emails
each week for added value this week Ryan
you and I went to a concert recently
maudlin the flame yeah the moth and the
flames great concert it's like I was
talking to Nate Peiffer who does the
music for our films he produced their
first album which is yeah they're
initially from Provo but they live in
Los Angeles so much so many good
musicians come out of Provo man right
unbelievable now the reason I wanted to
talk to you about them now their new
album is called ruthless and I
definitely recommend it it's like 11
different ruminations 11 songs 11
ruminations about modern-day rumination
in a way yeah and there's some great
songs on there there's a song called
beautiful couch where it's about how a
sort of loved loved one or significant
other moves on from you and we are like
looking at them on Instagram we're
stalking them on Instagram it's a whole
song about stalking someone on Instagram
yeah that's a great song there's another
one called do what you love and it's
sort of about bucking your parents
expectations so you can like pursue what
you're passionate about what a great
song the song we're gonna end today with
is called the new Great Depression
and when they sang this song it's a song
about depression like not the Great
Depression as in the 1920s and financial
depression but the new Great Depression
is like we're all feeling alienated
lonely anxious yeah and there's a lot
because we're connecting more than any
other time in the world with people
across the world right
but it's yes it's one of III agree with
what their what they're saying is it's
still one of the it's it's one of the
most connecting times but also one of
the loneliest times and if the line from
that song is the voice in my head is
ruthless and while they were singing
this song on stage this giant seven-foot
monster comes into the audience yeah and
there's this monster in my head that is
ruthless and he introduced hears
ruthless here's the seven-foot monster
yeah and he encouraged people to hug
ruthless as he came through the crowd
these giant eyes now he's also in the
video so if you're watching this on
YouTube Jordan maybe put a link to the
the video for the new Great Depression
there's a great video of this kid who's
feeling depression and eventually he
warms up and starts to get along with
ruthless the monster it's a phenomenal
song the reason I like their music I
always liked their music it was the
first time I ever saw them live yeah
it's the lead singer Brandon has such a
stage presence you could tell he is like
he's like meant to be up there in a way
right yeah now you mentioned Provo great
music scene there and there's a venue
there called the velour which you and I
have been to the guy who owns a Cory Fox
needed a kidney transplant a few years
ago oh wow he was he was gonna die
without it
Brandon the lead singer the moth aflame
gave his kidney get out of here Cory Wow
so he gave one of his kidneys I'm such a
good dude and such a great album let's
play them out today with the moth and
the flame this is the new Great
Depression and if you leave here today
with just one message all we hope it's
this love people and use things because
the opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
minimus